what do you think's more more dangerous
skid row or south central l.a johnny
me myself i i say uh skid row i've lived
in both of them you know i mean um
as a gang member you know what i mean
and i didn't really have enemies in
south central but i've seen a lot of
[ __ ] go down in south central this is
the difference between south central and
downtown
i was in south central and i was at a
stoplight i'm in my car
i pull it to the stop light and i look
caddy corner from me there's a laundry
mat
there's a gate
and i see
a dude
walk out the gate
he has a slingshot on a pair of shorts
he got the biggest [ __ ] gun i've ever
seen he got that in his waist he has his
hand on it
now i knew it's two in the afternoon
he cuts the corner where i could see him
he has his hand on his gun and he looks
around he goes down the street he walks
out and then right behind him
his girlfriend walks out pregnant
pushing a stroller with a baby in there
and i'm thinking man
i tell my homie look once i'm central
though check this [ __ ] out so i
show my homie he sees the strap and
everything
my whole thing was
you know just the guy having the strap
visible walking like he didn't give a
[ __ ] if the cops were there he [ __ ]
was looking and then had his girlfriend
stepping behind him that [ __ ] right
there that's like taking it
above above that that above that that's
what everybody please i'll say right now
it's getting whoa
now skid row is
a very very dark place
what i mean by that is
it like every year it changes it changes
like every year but
the thing about skid row is
you know
in south central they don't have a lot
of tents like skid row it really has
tents where there's guys that go inside
those tents and don't come out for
three months six months you might see a
[ __ ] and then you don't see them
for a whole year and you're like hey
were you in jail you're busted
no i live right there
you've been in that tent this whole
[ __ ] year and i ain't seen you
because a lot of people you know um like
for instance fentanyl you know a lot of
people do it and they just want to stay
still they don't want to go nowhere you
know what i've noticed about fentanyl is
it's a very lazy drug and it's here you
know in downtown and
you know it it
you know it changed it changed
the environment
it changed the style
of a [ __ ] who use who uses
opiates
the example i can give you is you got a
heroin user and you got a set no user
see the heroin usually could slam in the
morning
and then he's good all the way until
like three in the afternoon but fentanyl
user
gets high in the morning
and then about 45 minutes later
you start to sweat
your nose starts to run and this is only
45 minutes
you gotta
get high again
and this is just all through the day all
through the day so what i noticed about
fentanyl was
number one
it has so many side effects it
if i would have knew it had this many
side effects i never would have touched
this [ __ ] but it has so many side
effects and they're all long term none
of them are short term
you see guys walking around with their
back bent like you might have made my
maybe you have seen a razorback pig you
know their backs are like
they go exactly like that well there's
people out there that their backs are
shaped like that
and then their head is pushed all the
way down to their chest
and for some reason they get a big ass
ball
behind her neck
you know i went i went
up by main up there in the top and i
seen these three individuals
and i had to stop my bike and get off
because i've never seen anything like
this
these three individuals were
all kneeling down facing each other
all their backs were shaped like a
[ __ ] rainbow just i've never seen a
back like all their backs are shaped
like that all their heads were down
they looked like aliens i thought i
wanted to stop and look at him because
i've never seen anything like that and
then it was weird because
they all had their things out and they
were all getting high and everything but
then when they all got up
it was like
they stood up but they didn't actually
stand up because their [ __ ] head was
all the way like to their knees
you know and then i asked them i stopped
one of them i said hey man
do you see your [ __ ] back hurt
yeah well that's why it's like this i
said yeah but you know i read up on it
and it's it's not your back it's not
actually your back what it is it's it's
your kidneys
your kidneys is what it's attacking the
fentanyl attacks your kidneys
and it gives you kidney failure now
everybody's saying oh my [ __ ] backers
and what they do is go my back hurts all
my back hurts all my back hurts all my
back hurts pretty soon they're all the
way down like this and this is the only
way they feel relief
if they get up like this
their back just your back just
constantly it just it just hurts it
throbs so when you bend down like this
you take pressure off it i guess that's
why all those people are bent like that
because of the fact that that's what the
fentanyl does the fentanyl attacks your
kidneys you're thinking your back hurts
it's not your back it's your kidneys but
just to relieve your back a little you
want to bend over pretty soon
you're bent like that [ __ ] razorback
pig
and i mean that that
i've seen a lot of people on drugs i've
seen people on marijuana cocaine uh pcp
acid
but i've never seen anybody in the the
way you the way your body
the way the drug attacks your body that
fentanyl it number one it kills you fast
if you do too much number two
if you come down here and schedule and
you go and look at these guys that use
it you will notice that
it just attacks the body it bends them
in half you know what i mean and and and
it it it it makes your attitude
um
how could i put it you become more
greedy you become more self-reliant with
heroin you know you might see somebody
on the street and he's sick
you're getting well but with that and
all
there's people that see people sick and
they don't even get them well
now you know um and we're using the
heroin it was a big difference because
everybody's getting everybody well with
the fentanyl it's like if you ain't got
money or you ain't part of this group
you ain't getting [ __ ] you know i mean
you ain't getting [ __ ] and i mean
it's so [ __ ] up because it's so
[ __ ] expensive
but yet they don't even give you [ __ ]
you don't mean you get nothing in there
but
50 bucks man you pay 50 dollars man you
might get
[ __ ]
like the size of a [ __ ] tylenol pill
no no hell no half a tylenol pill for 50
bucks and you're getting love you know
i've been to places where i've seen
somebody grab something and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that dog
oh that's like twenty dollars and it's
nothing it's nothing it's [ __ ] powder
if you open that [ __ ] and the wind hits
it it's gone and you know dudes are
paying 20 bucks you know more power to
him you know hey
you know i mean you know it's just
i just don't understand it because it it
it
all the heroin users have flipped over
to fentanyl and and everybody's like
saying oh well it's better because you
don't spoke your veins no more you don't
got to use rigs
but yeah you know the best advice i
could give to anybody is if you're going
to use this [ __ ] read up on the [ __ ]
because the shit's going to tell you
that
the side effects on that [ __ ] are are
[ __ ] forever they don't go away in a
couple years your back doesn't get
straight automatic again once you bend
like that you're [ __ ] bent over
you're done you might as well join those
dudes up there and walk like them
because
you know they're walking and their heads
almost hitting the ground
you know and it's just i find it so
weird because
i would think if i was down like that
man
i'd be irritated my back would be
hurting but they're saying that the way
they're bent they're relieved they feel
good they feel like normal and i'm
telling them dude you're not normal bro
the way you look right now is not normal
you know
i've seen a lot of you use heroin i use
hearing with older cats that yeah they
used to bend down
and be all the way down whether your
head was almost hitting the ground but
they didn't have that
that razor back look you know where your
[ __ ] back actually [ __ ] makes
like like like a rainbow and it looks
nasty man
another thing that that shit's doing is
what i read about is
it's attacking your ankles
what it does is it attacks your pores
your hairs
and it and it creates scabs because it
starts to itch so you scratch it and you
scratch it you know maybe your hands are
dirty you irritate your legs and then
all of a sudden
it turns into some stuff it starts with
the m i'm trying to get the name of it
musa or mrsa
mrsa comes i've seen these girls man and
i'm just gonna i'm put up there because
you know i speak the real when i'm up
here i've seen this girl and i was in
love with this girl when i got here man
i was chasing her around for two years
i seen her the other day oh my god i was
walking and i seen this girl
her head was like
but like hanging off her shoulder you
know like and she had a big ass ball
right here
and she was like johnny huh i was like
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is that
what the hell is wrong with her because
her head was like i'm telling you it was
like all the way over here
and
and she's real skinny with a big ass
head
but i'm being honest when she came
oh man i was on her bumper she's so
[ __ ] fine
let's get back to what i'm saying though
so she's on her side she's
johnny johnny
and i'm like
is that you and she's like yeah it's me
and i'm like what the [ __ ] come here
so she came by me and i said
what what's going on you know
you know like i said i was in love with
this girl i'm like what's going on with
you you know
you let yourself go what she's like it's
the fat no it's the fact no
i said there you go you're like the rest
of them
as soon as i say something's wrong with
only if the phenomenon's doing it
they're blaming me and setting off for
everything now this girl like i said
mind you very attractive woman very
attractive woman man
she's real fatigue and small
now she looks like a 15 year old little
boy
you know straight
shaved her [ __ ] head off because she
said she had bugs in her hair
she didn't [ __ ] have bugs in her hair
what they do is they pick their head so
much that they create scabs
and then they pick the scab and they
feel that that scab
that that that there's bugs in there and
there's also bugs in their head
so then they pick their [ __ ] head
where they got big ass red spots
let alone scratching
us and then don't even wash your hands
scratch your legs and then go straight
and scratch right here scratch right
here i seen um
swords that they get on their lips i
don't know if that's from
you know the way they cook the smoke the
fat and all you have to get something
real hot and then hit the vent on
but some people are so high that they
get that [ __ ] hot
and accidentally turn the [ __ ] around
and instead of putting the hot in in the
[ __ ] they put the hot end in their mouth
that [ __ ] hurts
i know from experience i'll put it one
time oh [ __ ] burn all the inside not the
outside but some people
they actually burn on the outside and
then and the inside and their lips all
[ __ ] up
big old cuts
and for some reason
they're all peeking at kicking that one
of my homies has a spot like this bit
he's had that [ __ ] for like four
[ __ ] years man five years
it was a dead spot
no hair whatsoever just
red spot and it's just caked with meat
and blood and he's constantly
uh
and i'm like
come on dog stop that already man leave
it alone
nah something little bugs are in there
you know that that's the one thing that
i find very very
interesting with people around here that
use crystal masks
you know that no
you know uh any drug that that keeps you
awake and keeps you doing things i
noticed that these people
a lot of them are saying that
there's
a virus or there's a bug
you know or there's there's a new you
know a new something that was created
here in downtown and it's attacking you
from your from your feet up a lot of
people are saying that their feet are
hurting
you know i mean that they feel
electricity coming from the ground up
through their feet you know and a lot of
people are saying this not just it's not
just people are hiding they're just
talking no i've heard this from
numerous
numerous people from different areas you
know from different spots and they're
telling me that something's attacking
their feet you know and then it gets to
their ankles and then it creates big
holes
then once it creates those holes you
know there's one of my homies that
he sat next to me the other day man
and i was like what the [ __ ] is that dog
what the [ __ ] is that homie and he's
like oh man i'm sorry dog i'm sorry dog
i've had these pants on for like five
days
my leg dog like
i go you're like what dog what the [ __ ]
is that smell dog why is he dug his
death dog i can smell death dog what the
[ __ ]
why is it smelling like he said man
he was the best thing i could tell you
man is that i was walking
and from the bottom of my pants
meat and skin was falling off
i said what the [ __ ]
you were walking it yeah it goes in and
meat and skin were falling off the
bottom of my pants making a trail
i said off your own [ __ ] leg he's
like yeah i said
five days you've been with the same
pants
can you pick it up and show me
oh my god oh my god man i [ __ ] want
i didn't want to hurt my homie
but
i kind of took it overboard but i made
him go to the hospital because
he had chunks
of his leg
were gone
gone
you could see the vertical braids you
could see the veins you could see
everything on his [ __ ] leg different
spots now
but one spot was on the side
and i swear there was like seven larva
seven maggots in his [ __ ] hole in his
leg and i was like dude you got [ __ ]
maggots in your leg he's all yeah
they're good for my
wait up let me rewind the tape
you're telling me that
maggots are in your skin in your body
and they're good for you
well yeah because they told me that that
the larva eats
all the bacteria and all the bad [ __ ]
i go you know what that [ __ ] lover
turns into right a flock you know i say
you know what that larva's doing right
yeah it's in your [ __ ] skin i go but
dude you actually have worms in your
body me myself and i can't speak for no
one else so all you out there i mean i
can't have [ __ ] maggots falling out
of my body there's no [ __ ] way i'm
i'm gonna sit there and be comfortable
and eat or [ __ ] talk to a [ __ ] i
want to get busy whatever you don't mean
or lay down with her and i gotta tell
all but you know i gotta tell you first
[ __ ] there's gonna be maggots falling
on the side of my [ __ ] [ __ ]
i know my homie had seven maggots i
counted them
then one found he's like oh put it back
put it back
you know i don't know i don't know what
what people uh are talking about out
here or or
what they feel they know
but like if you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about you really
shouldn't give nobody any [ __ ] up
advice because you know first of all
you're not a doctor second of all you
know if you feel that you know
you should have bugs in your body
because they make you feel better and
they're healing you
[ __ ] we would have been born
with bugs in our body you know bugs
would just came in our body when we
first came out the whole [ __ ] woman
bugs were supposed to be in you bugs are
not supposed to be in you all that [ __ ]
i'm hearing out there about
it's okay if maggots are in your cut
they're [ __ ] healing it
dude your [ __ ] [ __ ] is rottening
you're falling apart your body's dying
that's why there's maggots in you when
you pass away and they bury you in the
grave
maggots are in your body when you're
dead so in other words
his leg is already dead
you know it looks so bad that i told the
blood
i'ma [ __ ] you up you know i'ma [ __ ] you
up just because
you know and he carries a pistol i don't
give a [ __ ]
i told him i'm gonna [ __ ] you up dog and
then i'ma kick your leg real [ __ ]
hard you know i'm kicking right real
hard cause i'm gonna send you to the
hospital now because you're trying to
tell me you're gonna go home to your
sisters and then she's gonna clean it up
homie i can't even stand the smell of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] smells so
[ __ ] bad mark i mean i couldn't i
can't even explain to you
the the the the stench
that i [ __ ] smell when you're sitting
next to me and i'm telling him homie
he's not a bad looking dude i don't
check [ __ ] out but he's not a
bad looking dude i've seen him with some
pretty nice women
but how is a woman gonna want to sit
next to this [ __ ] when his
[ __ ] leg is [ __ ] dying
chunks are falling out at the bottom of
his pants that right there blew my mind
when he told me that i was like
chunksy like why'd yeah pieces of meat
dog chunks in me are just falling out
and i'm like
does it doesn't that scare you i mean me
myself
if my leg was like
i'd be really scared man you know i'd go
to the hospital just to get a handle
there's people out here man that they
they have
big [ __ ] homes man in their [ __ ]
laser in their [ __ ] arm their back
people [ __ ] abscesses like that in
their back man this [ __ ] big man
three or four of them or they can't even
lay down
shirt all full of pus
i don't knock nobody for that
because i've had my own
but
there's some people out here that can
schedule that just take it that extra
mile you know what i mean they
they make it they try to make their
wound
and their cuts and everything they have
they try to make them uh they try to
speak them into uh
existence world war or no i'm okay they
actually
tell themselves that they're okay
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are if your
[ __ ] leg is falling enough you're not
okay
your legs are not supposed to fall off
you're not supposed to have big holes in
your [ __ ] body you're not supposed to
have maggots in your [ __ ] you know what
i mean
if you got maggots and your shit's
infected and purple and pus is coming
out and all this [ __ ]
and you think oh the mega is going to
make it better
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
but i mean i've heard this the reason i
address it because i've heard it several
times from different individuals in
different races that if you have maggots
you're okay nah man don't don't believe
no [ __ ] like that don't believe don't
let somebody shoot hot air up your ass
or piss on your head and tell you it's
ringing because that's what they're
doing you know what i mean they're
setting you up for death because if they
tell you it's okay to have magnus in
your body your body's dying you're gonna
get gangrene and then they're just gonna
[ __ ] start chopping they're gonna
chop and they don't give a [ __ ] they'll
chop your [ __ ] right here they'll chop
your [ __ ] right here and they ain't
gonna give a [ __ ] and believe me
your life will [ __ ] make a dramatic
change once they chop your [ __ ] leg
off because there's no more getting up
and i'm gonna go over here oh i'm gonna
do this you ain't gonna do [ __ ] all
you're gonna do is sit there till the
[ __ ] pushes you and then you're
gonna be able to go somewhere then
you're gonna become an [ __ ] because
you're gonna want everybody to push
you're gonna think you have that right
you know you're first on everything
because
you're like an idiot you let your leg
get so bad that they chopped it off now
you want to lay there and act like it's
[ __ ] up
you're not going to be able to live the
same way once one of your limbs gets cut
off i know
from experience i i i got a homie right
now they chopped his [ __ ] off and it
changed his whole life
he was like top dog right here
him he you hear his name it's like bam
that's
that's it here's his name that's it
whatever says his name and boom that's
where it's gonna happen that's how it
stays
i seen him the other day man
and he didn't want to get up out of bed
he didn't
he only got one there but i mean he
didn't want to get up and get pushed or
nothing
and i i kind of told him i mean
you know who you are right i mean i just
had to give him a
you know a little bit a little bit of
insight a little bit of a reminder
you know who you are right i mean [ __ ]
don't move unless you
let it move you know you you got to
understand you got to come back to
reality he's an older gentleman but i
had to give him a reality check because
he had to come back to reality because
she don't move unless
he he has he he puts it in play and
here cinder didn't want to do nothing
and it all started from him
smoking the fentanyl you know what i
mean there's so many people that are
smoking that [ __ ]
and they
[Music]
blow up they blow up because what this
drug does to you is it makes you lazy
it makes you drag it makes you
procrastinate and for you people that
don't procrastinate procrastinating you
put these [ __ ] off till later you know
and that's just not too cool everybody
knows when you push it off till later
sometimes it don't work out later you
know you plan it on but you get there
and it's all [ __ ] up well that's what
fentanyl has you do you know you want to
go to the hospital and it all sounds
good like you're going to go
but you take that hit and that dope just
shuts your whole body down where you
don't want to leave anymore you don't
want to go to the hospital now you want
to sit here and smoke dope with your
[ __ ] leg falling off
i just see it i see it and i i share
down here because you know i'm seeing
this now like today and in the past
couple of weeks where
you know a lot of people are
starting to use fentanyl you know and
and out there to those people that are
want to walk up and and lie and say oh
are you fed no and you want to take a
hit
remember [ __ ] when you die
you lied you lying from from jump and
said you smoke that [ __ ] if you don't
smoke that no i advise you not to take a
[ __ ] hit because you'll die that [ __ ]
will kill you everybody knows that that
[ __ ] will kill you you know i mean
there's [ __ ] out there
i don't understand them they see a
pretty woman whatever she's smoking they
want to come up and hey baby i get to
hear that girl and they'll never even
smoke
and this dumb [ __ ] gives it to him and
i gotta call him a dumb [ __ ] because
the dumb [ __ ] gave it to him knowing he
doesn't use knowing he's gonna die right
now
he'll hit it fall straight out
[ __ ] ain't gonna do nothing whoever
dudes are they're gonna have to bring
this dude back and everything it's just
i advise the people that never use
fentanyl i advise you to stay away from
it because it's not all what it seems
you know everybody makes it sound like
it's ten times better than heroin that's
a [ __ ] lie
it's not ten times better than heroin
because you have to do it every 45
minutes heroin you could slam and you go
for six hours so how in the [ __ ] do you
say
fentanyl is better than heroin when
fentanyl you got to do every 45 minutes
and heroin you can slam every [ __ ]
couple of hours
it's not better [ __ ] are
letting people tell them that and
they're putting it out there that oh
it's ten times better oh it's a hundred
times stronger
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] all you're
[ __ ] doing is you're [ __ ] doing
some [ __ ] that they tranquilize your
body with
when they don't want you to move so you
won't hurt yourself in the hospital
that's the last [ __ ] they give you they
give you fentanyl so you won't move so
all that [ __ ] about you don't mean uh is
heroin ten times better than heroin no
it's not even close to heroin because
heroin is grown
and this [ __ ] is man-made it's just a
synthetic [ __ ] heroine that we're
doing
but
it just takes
more from you more from your [ __ ]
life you know it just pulls away it
pulls away you don't even see it man you
know
beforehand my friends that have all
those cuts on on themselves
even the girls
they don't see it they don't see it they
don't see that that's a problem
they feel this is the excuse these well
i'm not the only one with the bump on my
neck i'm not the only one with my back
bent
what the [ __ ] are you serious you're not
the only one
[ __ ] how can you even say
something like how how does somebody
even come to terms with that where well
everybody else is back then so my back's
been too
what the [ __ ] i used heroin a lot of
years my back didn't get bent
my [ __ ] [ __ ] bill [ __ ] ball in
the back of my neck walking around
you can't even look up they can't be
people that are like this they can't
even look up when they talk to you they
gotta look all the way back like and
you're like [ __ ] are you all right you
know you wanna just [ __ ] like
just [ __ ] hip go back up you know a
couple of times i just want to give them
a [ __ ] uppercut just to see you know
their [ __ ] and blow it but
i don't want to do that because that
big-ass ball i don't know what it is
but it's [ __ ] hard it's
it's like the [ __ ] size of us of a
softball
and it's [ __ ] big man either right
here on the side or right in the middle
the one in the middle
from where they gather that one hurts
more than the one on the side remember
the one that site says your [ __ ] head
like it puts your [ __ ] head way on
the side you know what i mean that [ __ ]
don't look too cool you know being bent
over don't look cool but having your
[ __ ] head over here right in your
shoulder does not look cool
especially when you're a woman you know
i mean i'm on these women out here
because
i'm a strong believer and i try to make
the women a little bit better out here
because it's much harder for them in the
skid row you know a woman has a lot of
problems on it i ran into a lot of them
where they've been done dirty you know
they're crazy because [ __ ] made
them crazy you know foods did dirty [ __ ]
to them you know i mean and i see them
you know i mean and a lot of them i try
to talk to them and tell them you know
maybe you need to do this maybe you need
to do that maybe you need to go home you
know maybe you need to stop doing this
drug do some of this maybe you need to
do less you know i never try to tell
anybody stop i try to tell maybe you
need to do less
because of the fact that you know um
and then the one thing i hear in my life
is it people say oh no i don't smoke it
on on tinfoil i only smoke on glass
oh my god what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you know what i mean
you're smoking speed on on [ __ ] tin
foil way before even glass came out you
know but i'm saying you know a lot of
people
get the the misunderstanding that
because you smoke on glass uh it's
the tinfoil will [ __ ] you up and the
glass won't
you're an idiot
the fentanyl is going to [ __ ] you up
anyways it doesn't matter if you smoke
it on your hand if you're smoking a
cigarette if someone had a joint you
smoked on [ __ ] temple or a [ __ ]
glass pipe you're gonna get the same
[ __ ] results
the same [ __ ] results you're gonna
get the same [ __ ] up [ __ ] crooked
back [ __ ] big ol ball so all that
about i only smoke on glass
that's just a persona you're putting in
your [ __ ] head it's just a smoke
screen to tell yourself that it's okay
it's not let's go ahead and keep smoking
on glass whatever smoke around 10 4
whatever you can do you're still harming
your body the same way it doesn't matter
so yo oh you smoke tampon you get those
chemicals in there
man come on man that's him for you they
[ __ ] cook meat on it and [ __ ] they
miss me with that [ __ ] there's
there's chemicals that get you miss me
with that [ __ ] because they wouldn't
put tinfoil out for people to cook on it
if they [ __ ] had poison on it but
people actually say oh you'll get
poisoned from the [ __ ]
you know the tinfoil but you know i
share that with people because
i use a lot of drugs and
through my life and
i don't
i don't put vietnam in the drug category
i don't put it in the drug category it
it's so
by itself
alone it does so much damage that
i don't even put it right here with
heroin and coke and all that i put that
[ __ ] separate
it has its separate thing because
it changes people's style
it keeps you at home so you don't come
out and you [ __ ] get big and fat we
can't move
and then it gives you all those sores on
your legs
you know it attacks your kidneys makes
your back bent you know i mean so
you know when those people are out there
saying well i don't use hair and i don't
slam anymore i don't poke my van
yeah but you're smoking [ __ ] fat and
on your [ __ ] backs gonna get bent
you're gonna get all [ __ ] up
i would rather get an abscess than have
my back bent like that you know what i
mean but
i just share that with people because so
many people
are trying to make a phenomenal look
like it's better than heroin that's a
[ __ ] lie it's not it's worse
it's worse heroines heroin is better
than [ __ ] phantom i know i've used
them both
they're completely opposite that's when
people mention them together i see
they're not the same
they're not the same [ __ ] don't
act like the way they act on
you know i mean you [ __ ] turn your
head turned back and your [ __ ] torch
is gone everything what the [ __ ]
person right next to you stole it and
you said
i didn't see it
that's how bad that knows don't rob your
ass blind they don't give a [ __ ] who it
is whatever the way for you to smoke and
wait for you to nod out
and then they just rip you and they just
rape your ass take everything
you wake up you've got nothing in your
pockets you're pulled out like rabbit
ears
i've seen it i've seen it i watched
[ __ ] get foods where they took
one hit and nodded out and they [ __ ]
took everything skateboard radio pipes
so you know you people that are out
there doing the phantom man you know the
best advice i can give you is
maybe you should do less or maybe you
should just stop and go to a different
drug because that that phenomenon was
killing a lot of people and
i'm pretty sure everybody out there
knows somebody that died from fentanyl
and some of the people that died from
fat and all was really [ __ ] up is
they didn't smoke it
they didn't use it
all they did was touch it
touched it all they did was touched it
and they od
it hits certain people different ways
[ __ ] say oh i touch it all the
time i i don't know d
that's because you're strong out idiot
you know you've been using but people
that
advice to people that never [ __ ] with
fennel you see it don't touch it don't
[ __ ] touch it you don't got to touch
it
leave it there because if you touch it
you're going to die that's just the way
it is for those [ __ ] want to
take that hit
if it's your first hit
go ahead take a big ass hit you're gonna
die
if you're gonna slam it
i don't slam that [ __ ] at all
because you slam it you die
little ass bit like that you're dead
and that that [ __ ] uh [ __ ] that
brings you back that narcan
on heroin you can narcan somebody once
they'll come right back i'm setting on
you gotta hit him like three four or
five times with the narcan and then they
barely come back so you know
i share that today you know i wanted to
come and share about that fentanyl
because it's out here
really looking deep
and
you know i come up here and speak the
truth
i don't come here to speak lies a lot of
people are putting a lot of lies on that
fentanyl i think if you're gonna use it
just be direct with it because all those
lies they're putting on top of it and
making it look like it's it's it's a
wonder drug that's [ __ ]
it's gonna kill you and make your back
bent
you wanna look come to downtown go up
there on main and just stand over there
and you'll see what i'm talking about
you'll see the guys roll by
and you'll know who's on phantom because
their [ __ ] back is bent
and you'll see what i see you know what
i mean and then you can make your own
judgment but me myself
i don't understand
how these people let that drug take so
much effect on them you know i mean
leg falling off
[ __ ] maggots in your skin
maggots in your body
that it's okay
nah man it's not okay man
don't let that drug make you think that
it's okay to have maggots in your body
you know
i i feel that's very [ __ ] up you know
if you're out there that
are gonna use drugs and you know do your
homework on them first man read up on
them you know study them you know before
you [ __ ] do it you don't gotta do it
right then and there you can study it
whatever and then do the drug you know i
can't tell you not to but i mean
read about it you know people are doing
fat no read that read about it
go to your phone and read about it see
how much side effects this [ __ ] see what
this [ __ ] is doing to america and doing
to us because they put it out here for
the [ __ ] on the streets it's
just another eliminator
there's instead of giving you a [ __ ]
hro little house they're just gonna give
you a permanent [ __ ] bed and it's
gonna be in the dirt
that's all they did that's all they did
was just put the fitting out here just
to
move more homeless out the way you know
what i mean
it's a drug epidemic [ __ ] you
want to move more [ __ ] out the way
because you don't want to make more
housing for people you know that that's
the way i see it i see it that they're
population control and doing it
different different ways you know
vietnam was just another thing they
threw out there
i mean and it's not 10 times better than
heroin that's a [ __ ] lie
it's not even heroin it's a [ __ ] pill
you know
prince michael jackson all those fools
died from fentanyl
but the [ __ ] still go use it you
know you see michael jackson died prince
died [ __ ] still going to use it
it just doesn't make sense and you know
that drug makes you believe things that
are
not true i just want to share that today
mark you know
about the fentanyl man because a lot of
people are dying man
i don't want to see
people that i know
dropping now there's so many people that
died in skid row this last six months
where it's all different everybody's
dead what the [ __ ] happened i left for
like eight months i come back
everybody's dead
what the [ __ ] what happened
phantom killed them all
that's what they say
you got to be honest that's what they
say
just be careful out there with that fat
no man buddy hellmark all right john
thank you yeah i wanted to get out the
mud
you